dear NYPD
we here at aj+ know you're busy you do
have one of the biggest cities in the
world to police and you are reeling from
the deaths of two of your own
but since crime is actually at record
lows in New York City not to mention New
York State oh and since the New York
Post reported you're choosing not to
police as much these days
we hope you'll have time for this one
short message you can turn your backs on
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio
but please don't turn your backs on the
residents of your city or on everyone
else in your country let's back up a
little yes this started with one
officers toke hold of Eric garner but
it's about way more than one officer or
even the entire NYPD it's about more
than Michael Brown who was shot a few
weeks later and a thousand miles away
from New York it's even about more than
the two non indictments of the cops that
killed them it's about what people see
as systemic racism about how the system
seems rigged against people of color and
it's about the huge role that the police
play in this system and there's a lot of
history not to mention even more
evidence to back that up like how from
2002 to 2011 your own officer stopped
and searched people millions of times on
the streets of New York and a staggering
90% of the people you searched were
black or Latino out of all the people
you frisked 88% of the time 3.8 million
stops they were innocent does that sound
fair but again this isn't just about you
nationwide black Americans were almost
four times as likely as White's to be
arrested for marijuana possession in
2010 even though both groups used the
drug at the same rate does that sound
fair and even though blacks are just 12%
of the total population of drug users in
the u.s. they make up 59% of folks in
state jails on drug offenses does that
sound fair now you're supposedly really
upset with your mayor because in the
aftermath of Eric Garner's death he said
this about his own biracial son with
Dante very early on my son we said look
give a police officer stops you do
everything he tells you to do don't
move suddenly don't reach for your
cellphone because we knew sadly there's
a greater chance that might be
misinterpreted if it was a young man of
color but given some of these stats why
is that so crazy if the President of the
United States can say that Trayvon
Martin could have been him 35 years ago
if the President himself says he's been
followed in a department store for no
apparent reason
then why can't the mayor say he's
worried for his own son and why can't we
the recent killings of NYPD officers
rafael ramos and wenjian who are
horrible and tragic and our hearts go
out to their families nobody wants to
see police officers get shot but the
deranged men who killed the officers has
nothing to do with Eric garner and
Michael Brown or the civil rights
movements their death sparked no matter
what insane words he used to justify his
actions now we know not every officer
turned their back on de Blasio in the
hospital where the officers were taken
or at rama's funeral and we know not
every officer booed him at a recent
police graduation congratulations
officers we know not every police
officer is the same and that people
don't wake up in the morning with the
intention to racially profile again this
is bigger than any one single officer
it's about the country about the culture
and about whether people can trust those
who are supposed to be protecting them
so NYPD please don't turn your back on
New York City or the rest of your
country most people just want what the
Constitution guaranteed them a long long
time ago but that still seems so out of
reach equal treatment under the law
you